mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
the american invitational mathematics
examination
or amy for short is a qualifying test in
america
for the international mathematical
olympiad
the test is 3 hours long and there are
15 questions
calculators are not allowed every answer
on the test
is a whole number from 0 to 999
inclusive today's video is adapted from
problem 3
of the 2019 amy you have a triangle
we're going to cut off each corner of
the triangle
we will do that by making straight line
cuts or each endpoint of the line
segment
is a distance of 5 from a vertex of the
triangle
we do this for each of the three
vertices of the triangle
the remaining distances are equal to 5
10 and 15. the question
is what is the area of the hexagon
that's shaded
i think assad for the suggestion pause
the video if you'd like to give this
problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
so how can we solve this problem there
are many ways to solve this problem
but i will illustrate one of the methods
in this video
first let's calculate the side lengths
of the triangle
one side length is equal to 15 another
side length is equal to 20
and the third side length is equal to 25
now we notice that 15 squared plus 20
squared is equal to 25 squared
therefore this triangle is a right
triangle
and the right angle is between the two
sides that have lengths of 15 and 20.
so let's draw a little more accurate
version of this triangle
from here we'll notice that this right
triangle
has sides in the ratio of three to four
to five
so it's a scaled up version of the three
four five right triangle
we thus can use similar triangles to
deduce the lengths of the altitudes of
the two triangles in the corners
we can take this three four five right
triangle to the right corner
and see that the altitude is equal to
three we'll take this to the top corner
and we'll see that the altitude is equal
to four
we're now ready to solve this problem
the area of the hexagon will be equal to
the area of the entire triangle
minus the areas of the triangles in the
three corners
but we know the base and the height of
each of these triangles so we can
calculate each of these areas
the entire triangle has an area equal to
15 times 20 all over 2.
this next triangle has an area that's
equal to 5 times 5 over 2
then the next area is equal to 5 times 3
over 2
and the final area is equal to 5 times 4
over 2.
we can then carefully calculate each
area
then we simply need to do this
subtraction and we get
that the area of the hexagon is equal to
120
and that's the answer thanks for making
us one of the best communities on
youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time